We're going to write a Python program
to check and see or to enumerate strings in this language
so that we can check strings for validity.
Here I've written a grammar, but it's on kind of a pencil and paper format
with these arrows and what-not.
I'm going to need to encode it so that Python can understand it
just like we had to encode the edges in our finite state machine
so that Python could understand them.
Here on the right I've written a potential Python encoding for this grammar.
Expression goes to expression plus expression.
The way I'm going to encode this is
if we had A goes to B, C, I'm going to make that the rule A goes to B, C.
We've got the left-hand side and the right-hand side,
left-hand side and the right-hand side.
Expression goes to expression plus expression.
Expression can also go to expression minus expression
or expression in parentheses, or just number,
and here I'm writing all of my terminals and non-terminals as strings
just to make equality checking easier.
Then given a seed utterance like print exp followed by semi-colon,
we would represent that as a list of 3 strings,
and what I want to do is take our grammar rules like this one
and our utterances like this one and combine them together
to get--I've replaced the expression that was already in here.
Using this rule, I've replaced it with expression minus expression.
Well, if I've stored this in a Python variable called "utterance,"
and the position I want to change is position 1--that's where I'm going to apply this rule--
I can get out this cool result with this Python
that uses list selection.
Utterance from 0 up to but not including pos,
this part here corresponds to this part in our example,
the word "print," something that came before the part we were interested in.
The right-hand side of the rule was expression minus expression,
and then the rest of the utterance, this semi-colon,
something else we weren't concerned with this time.